olivia rodrigo librio rodrigo is
apparently a popular musician i had
never heard of her until a month or two
ago when there was some story about
something she had done and i don't even
remember what she had done i apparently
she's a very popular musician has had a
bunch of number one songs and yet i
don't what do i know i'm not
this is not the sort of person that i
pay attention to
but i've now heard of her for the second
time and this is not because of any
music she's made it's because of
something she said
she said in a magazine interview quote i
sometimes get dms from little girls
being like
i've never seen someone who looked like
me in your position and i'm literally
going to cry like just thinking about it
rodrigo 18 said in the v magazine
feature i feel like i grew up never
seeing that also it was always like pop
star that's a white girl
so first of all this girl looks pretty
white i don't you know i guess she's
hispanic with a name like rodrigo but
she looks pretty white to begin with and
she's she's using this line that you you
constantly hear from the race hustlers
and and the victim people
and it says that you know growing up i
never saw oh she's philippe apparently
the producer is telling me she's
filipino okay whatever she just she
looks
oh i wouldn't know she's ethnically
ambiguous let's put it that way but
apparently this is the defining feature
of her personality of who she is
and
she
comes out and says you know it's i never
saw people who looked like me and the
little girls today never see anyone who
looked like them
now some people are responding and
saying hold on lady um ella fitzgerald
aretha franklin
uh hold on i pretty sure we've seen some
black popular musicians or hispanic
popular musicians before
and
or at least in i guess to go to her
example non-white popular musicians but
i want to be really fair
okay because she said pop star she said
pop stars were always white so yeah sure
maybe soul singers r b hip hop jazz
maybe they're black but
we've never seen non-white girl
pop stars right
so i took a little i just took a little
trip down google
looked up uh this girl olivia rodriguez
was born in 2003 apparently
2003 grammy for pop vocalist winner
norah jones indian woman grammy for pop
album goes to norman brown the black guy
grammy for pop vocal collaboration
santana hispanic and michelle branch
indo
2004 this is the next she's one year old
now pop vocalist christina aguilera
hispanic pop collaboration mary j bludge
2005 norah jones wins a bunch again
indian woman including one with ray
charles who's a black guy 2006 this is
all in the pop category stevie wonder is
a winner de la soul is a winner black
guys
2007 christina aguilera is a winner
black eyed bees winner stevie wonder al
gero
for this girl's entire life
it has seemed if you're just looking at
the billboard charts and you're just
looking at the grammys
there is no reason for any
non-white girl to think it is impossible
to become a big pop star if you're
non-white frankly
you would be more likely to think that
if you were a white girl
during this era
you you might if you were a white girl
during this area you might look at the
pop shorts and think man a white girl
just can't make it in this world this is
not the industry for white girls
looking at but
but because
we are living in surreal we're living in
unreality we're living
in a delusion
right now
many people believe this
we are living in a delusion the white
house is living in a delusion
the top military brass is living in a
delusion
all of us here in the culture are living
in a delusion
and delusions have consequences
because delusions run up against reality
sometimes
in kabul
in the united states
and when delusions run up against
reality reality wins
and it's not it's funny i mean we can
make fun of rodrigo or who we can make
fun of mark milley you know the
pink-haired woke chairman of the joint
chiefs we can make fun of that sergeant
at sergeant major we can make fun of but
but there are real world consequences
here hold up hold up
all right i'm glad you like that video
that's
that makes me feel very good if you want
to leave me a little comment about it
that would make me feel even better i
need you to subscribe both here on
youtube and
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play really helps to avoid some of the
big tech issues that we've had in some i
don't know i'm not blaming anybody but
sometimes they don't like what we say if
you go on over to apple podcast spotify
stitch your google play the michael
knowles show subscribe leave a five star
review
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]